♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SATURDAY SHOW.
IDENTITIES YE, THE ARTIST
FORMERLY KNOWN AS KANYE WEST,
TELLING TUCKER A TELL-ALL,
PRETTY MUCH.
IN PART TWO OF THE INTERVIEW, HE
SPOKE OUT ABOUT HIS FAITH AND
THE CRITICISM HE GOT FROM
HOLLYWOOD ABOUT SUPPORTING
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IT DROVE ME CRAZY TO NOT BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I LIKED TRUMP.
I NEVER ACTUALLY TOLD PEOPLE
THAT I LIKED TRUMP WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING BECAUSE I WAS BULLIED BY
HOLLYWOOD.
BECAUSE I STAYED IN HOLLYWOOD,
AND PEOPLE ARE, LIKE, THINK
ABOUT YOUR KIDS.
AND I'M TRYING TO HOLD ON TO THE
MARRIAGE, SO I'M JUST BITING MY
TONGUE.
LIKE, THERE'S SO MANY FATHERS
AND MOTHERS THAT GO TO WORK
EVERY DAY, ASK THEY'RE IN A
SITUATION -- AND THEY'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE BITING
THEIR TONGUE BECAUSE THEY THINK
IT WILL BE BETTER --
>> YES, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> -- FOR THEIR KIRP --
CHILDREN.
SO EVEN ME IN MY POSITION, I WAS
BITING MY TONGUE ON MY
POLITICALLEN OPINION BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE BETTER FOR
MY CHILDREN.
>> KANYE'S DOING IT TOO, WE KNOW
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID
THIS, AND THEY WERE SILENT WHEN
IT CAME TO POLLING BEFORE VOTING
IN 2016.
BUT HERE WE ARE AGAIN, AND HE'S
FINALLY SPEAKING OUT ABOUT IT TO
SHOW THIS IS GOING ON WITH
EVERYBODY.
>> YEAH.
I'M FIRED UP ABOUT THIS, AND
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO ME
FIRST.
I'M SURE I'M THE ONLY ONE HERE
WHO LISTENS TO RAP MUSIC.
>> WHAT?
[LAUGHTER]
STOP NOW.
>> WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE RAP
ARTIST IN.
>> WELL, WE'RE GOING BACK TO THE
EARLY '90s.
TUPAC, BIGGIE, I DON'T
DISCRIMINATE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I'LL DEYOU, IN HOLLYWOOD YOU
WILL GET SHUNNED IS, BUT
NOWADAYS YOU CAN GET SHUNNED
BEING IN CONNECTICUT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU ARE.
WHEN IT COMES TO CHRISTIAN
VALUES, WE'VE SEEN A CONSTANT
TREND THAT IF YOU VOCALIZE THAT,
PEOPLE WOULD SAY, YEAH, MAYBE
YOU SHOULDN'T BE WITH US, WE'RE
NOT APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
AND ESPECIALLY ME BEING A BLACK
CONSERVATIVE WHO'S WRITTEN A
BOOK CALLED TAKEN FOR GRANTED --
PICK THAT UP -- WITH ME IN THAT
SITUATION, I GOT SHUNNED IF FROM
MY OWN FAMILY MEMBERS.
PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY LOVE ME AND
SUPPORT ME, THIS WAS MANY YEARS
AGO.
SO I KNOW THAT THIS IS A
CONSISTENT THEME ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO BEING A BLACK PERSON
WHO'S SAYING THAT THEY'RE
CONSERVATIVE IN THIS COUNTRY IS
ALMOST LIKE YOU'VE GOT TO BE
CONTROLLED.
IF YOU DON'T SAY WHAT WE THINK
BLACK PEOPLE SHOULD SAY, THEN
YOU'RE SHUNNED.
AND THAT'S SO DISAPPOINTING,
DISGUSTING.
AND WE SEE IT A LOT WITH WHITE
LIBERALS.
THEY ARE THE PROBLEM ESPECIALLY
WHEN THIS --
>> BIDEN SAID IT, BY THE WAY --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE TOLD YOU.
>> THAT'S DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
ISSUES.
IT'S ABOUT RELIGION, LARA, IT'S
ALSO ABOUT ASSOCIATING YOURSELF
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, IT'S SO SAD AND IT'S SO
CRAZY.
I'VE GOT TO SAY, I REALLY
ENJOYED SO MUCH OF THIS INTERIF
SUE INTERINTERVIEW WITH KANYE
WEST.
IT WAS SO REFRESHING TO FINALLY
HAVE SOMEBODY COME OUT.
HE WASN'T WORRIED ABOUT HIS
BRAND, WASN'T WORRIED ABOUT HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA FOLLOWING.
IT FEELS LIKE WE DON'T GET
ENOUGH OF THAT THESE TODAYS --
>> UNFILTERED.
>> YES!
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO SAY YOU
SUPPORT WHOEVER YOU WANT.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, AND THE THINGS THAT
KANYE WEST WERE SAYING, THESE
WERE NOT GROUND-BREAKING THINGS.
TO SAY HE SUPPORTED DONALD
TRUMP, GREAT, SO DID 74 MILLION
AMERICANS.
TO SAY, ESSENTIALLY, THAT ALL
LIVES MATTER, SOMETHING THAT GOT
PEOPLE FIRED FROM THEIR JOBS,
CANCELED IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
RESPECTS TWO YEARS AGO, THAT'S
BASIC.
IF YOU BELIEVE THAT GOD IS THE
CREATOR OF ALL HUMANS AND ALL
THINGS, THEN ALL LIVES MATTER.
>> YEAH.
>> AND KANYE WEST SAID IT.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS SO NICE TO
GET SOMEBODY --
>> AND HE ACTUALLY ELABORATES ON
LIVING FOR GOD IN THE INTERVIEW,
SO I WANT TO JUST TAKE THIS
SOUND BITE TOO.
>> LIBERALS, THEIR -- WITH
LIBERALS, THEIR MAIN, YOU KNOW,
THEIR MAIN TOOL IS, YOU KNOW,
THAT THEY USE ARTISTS AND
INFLUENCE, INFLUENCERS, RIGHT?
BUT THEN GOD HAS THE NUMBER ONE
ARTIST, THE NUMBER ONE
INFLUENCER AS A CONSERVATIVE.
SO I ALWAYS CHUCKLE AT THAT.
CANDACE OWENS, AND WE BOTH WORE
THE SHIRT AT THE SAME TIME, YOU
KNOW?
WE GOT SOME JESUS SOLDIERS OUT
HERE.
AND PEOPLE SAY HEIR WILLING TO
DIE FOR IT, BUT WE LIVE FOR IT.
WE'RE LIVING FOR THE BATTLE.
AND WHAT'S THE BATTLE FOR?
IF LIFE ITSELF.
>> SEAN?
>> I LOVE THIS BECAUSE HE'S A
FREE HIKER, HE'S SPEAK HIS MIND
WHICH HE'S ENTITLED TO, TO
LARA'S POINT.
YOU KNOW, HALF OF AMERICA WON
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HE WON ONE ELECTION, LOST
ANOTHER, AND TO THINK THE THAT'S
AN UNACCEPTABLE VIEWPOINT IN
HOLLYWOOD, BUT THIS IS REALLY
THREATENING TO LIBERALS BECAUSE
HE'S COURAGEOUS.
HE'S SPEAKING THE TRUTH.
AND IF KANYE CAN SPEAK TRUTH,
MAYBE OTHER BLACK, RIGHT-LEANING
CONSERVATIVES CAN SPEAK THE
TRUTH, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
EMPEROR HAS NO CLOTHES, AND YOU
HAVE THIS EXPLOSION OF
CONVERSATION.
WHAT DO DEMOCRATS DO FOR THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY?
>> THEY'VE A FAILED US.
>> HOW IS MY LIFE BETTER?
YOU WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE?
LOOK WHAT IT DOES TO MY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU WANT TO OPEN THE BORDERS?
THE CRIME'S NOT IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU HAVE A GATED COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT CONVERSATION,
LIBERALS CAN'T HANDLE.
AND KANYE SPEAKING OUT WITH SUCH
A LARGE PLATFORM IS VERY
DANGEROUS TO DEMOCRATS WHICH IS
WHY THEY HAVE TO DESTROY HIM.
>> TWO QUICK POINTS.
WHAT I'VE SEEN IS OFTEN TIMES
MORE THAN NOT DEMOCRATS, BLACK
FOLKS DON'T MATTER, BLACK VOTES
DO.
AND WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO
KANYE WHEN HE MET WITH TRU